yeah i met muhammad ali when was that
oh it was during the when he was
uh doing speech you know when he was uh
barred from boxing
and he was uh just doing talks you know
he was uh tripping around and
yeah yeah that was very funny i got a
friend
a dancer friend of mine uh scarlett
was her name i i played one time played
in a
little circus and she was in one of the
dancers
and so we were friends and she and so i
told her i was going to
uh detroit
yeah i was on my way to detroit and i
was this was in san francisco
and so she told me oh she says oh you
won't you'll not won't believe who i
who i was with who i was hanging with
last night
and i said who she goes muhammad ali
and i said oh great how was she going
you know it was
it was muhammad ali camp in the world
yeah so then so then i get to detroit
and bobby
taylor calls me on the phone he goes hey
you want to meet the champ
and what yeah muhammad ali he's coming
over he's coming over
so come on back so so i got my car and i
drove and parked
got in the elevator and there's muhammad
ali in the elevator
and he doesn't know me and you know and
so we're riding up to the
to the bobby taylor floor and
muhammad lakes muhammad ali he's not
even looking at me you know kind of
looking over me you know did that yeah
and so i said uh
scarlett says to say hi
there just hit me and him in the
elevator and his eyes got all
big and he looked at me like
i was you know something magic happened
you know
because what are the odds of being in an
elevator with some guy
that knew about your little affair that
you're trying to keep quiet from the
world
[Laughter]
that's cool the next thing you know
you're in the elevator
and the guy goes zayn scarlett says hi
well
he just just stared at me just stared at
me and then we got off the elevator
and we're going to the same room place
because he's
going to meet bobby taylor him and bobby
were friends uh
during the olympics and so so then bobby
introduced us
you know and muhammad ali he then he
started
loosening up he was very happy then it
was very funny and i took pictures with
him but
you know no no one knows where the
pictures are now there
they disappeared did you guys share a
marijuana cigarette
no no no no bobby wasn't smoking no no
one was really smoking back then just me
you know i'm by myself
you know you know it was highly well you
know imagine he's on
you know he's barred from boxing he
didn't want to have to
deal with a drug wrap too you know right
was he he was barred from boxing for
like not joining the vietnam war or
something like that or what was that
yeah
yeah yeah yeah he uh he wouldn't he
wouldn't
uh yeah he wouldn't do the draft thing
and
and he encouraged a lot of people to
burn their draft cards
cheats was one of them saw muhammad ali
and then he burned his drop card and
then he went up to canada
so yeah we got a little little in-house
uh
connection there you know that's cool is
that how you ended up meeting cheech is
that he burned his draft card
and then went to canada and then you met
him yeah
yeah well because of muhammad ali
[Music]
all because of the girl scarlet dude
right yeah it's her spell scarlett she's
still
she's still cool she's she's she's a
buddy of mine
thanks so much for watching this clip
and if you drink
coffee you need a mug shot mug
that's my first ever mug shot and this
mug is available on
amazon as well as at stevo.com so go
ahead and click the link in the
description below
this is what you're gonna find and grab
yourself a mug shot
mug yeah dude
yeah dude